ja sollte herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video und dem titel heute mit
einer neuen trailer zu la frange am
start bevor wir aber loslegen muss ich
euch ein kurzes video zeigen das hat
heute eine zuschauerin hat oder
geschickt und keine ahnung ich bin mega
süß mega wird sich deswegen
das ist einfach mega süßes hat noemi a k
s gepostet dankeschön an ihren mega mega
cool leute die schon heute nicht
irgendwie denn ihr habt das auch im tv
gesehen es ist eine youtube kacke
special edition ja schon vor einiger
zeit mal so ein youtube kategorie action
video hochgeladen zu gemischten
reaktionen ich gesagt es gab relativ
viele likes aber es gab relativ discs
woraus ich schließe dass es einigen
leuten sehr gut gefallen hat und halt
einigen überhaupt ein kabarett probiert
es heute nochmal im rahmen dieser
trainer läuft es geht heute darum nicht
zu lachen und ich sage euch das ist bei
diesen videos sehr sehr schwer für mich
denn es sind so die das sind für mich
auf jeden fall den lustigsten videos auf
youtube der kanal von dem video
hersteller ist der erste liegt der
bestrahlung unbedingt abschicken und
weder die videos lustig findet last
unbedingt ein abo bei und seine original
video ist an zweiter stelle
da könnt euch das ganze video anschauen
denn wir wenn uns das heute ran karte
anschauen was zwei gründe hat einmal
reichen immer noch studieren und gar
nicht so mega viel zeit ab das video zu
machen ehrlich gesagt und zweitens weil
ich glaube dass es wichtig ist das ding
uncut zu gucken damit sich der humor der
ganzen sache entwickeln kann deswegen
heute mehr drin katz zu weit geht und
sagen film ab
challenge youtube kaka special edition
des lebens ist es probiert selbst mal
aus er setzt sich hin probiert nichts zu
lachen alles zusammen ist es gegen der
songs eines türstehers zum essen
angelangt hat genug übergab sich auf den
tisch
ich weiß nicht was sie da
das hat außer typ wieso diese kassen
gesichts verschärfe die süßen kräfte
sind echt schwierig muss wirklich an
mich halten weil sowas soll das sind
wirklich klappt es mich wirklich lachen
muss diesen einfach geil soßenbinder
sport andichten muss einfach geile
videos ohne witz sollte weil ich wieder
ernst
siehst du diese frauen
du hast mir zur begrüßung keine blase
sie hatten ihr sagt ich hier wenn
unaufhörlich den kopf du gehst du hast
mir nicht das haar spa gesagt sie hat
man an dass mit düften im ölgeschäft
deshalb sage ich dir lieb dich
das leben ist das teil 3 was ihr gerade
von das ist ein absoluter knaller ich
sollte ich vielleicht noch warten weil
sie so nicht gemerkt hat bisher die
sprache dieses videos verwendet wird es
ein bisschen sehr die rechtlichen vulgär
bisschen als schimpfwort deswegen alle
kinder unter drei jahren schalteten ein
könig der guru schöne wir kennen solche
wie ihn sie gestern predigen eine weile
und kommen sie sind schnell vergessen
hört gut zu ich möchte euch warnen wenn
dieser mann noch weiter fehlt mache ich
euch verantwortlich erlaubt den kindern
zu mir zu kommen hindert sie nicht daran
wer dieses kind von hinten nimmt den
gehört das reich gottes
wer aber nicht hineinkommen
so mal so und was beispielsweise so
witzig okay wir dürfen nicht nach wenn
ich lache am laufenden band was das
rätselhafte entschluss konzentrier dich
aua aua
als erstes kam wein lebt im tempel sah
fiskus zwei sehr kleinen titel ich will
euch eine frage stellen sagt mir stand
das recht dass johannes zu saufen von
gott oder von den menschen
sie sind überzeugt johannes war ein fest
ab wir wissen nichts dann werde ich auch
nicht sagen mit welchem recht nicht
laufen
es war ein mann der legte einen weinberg
an und reiste für längere zeit
was wird nun mit den [ __ ] tun
er wird den vitter töten und den
weinberg anderen wittern geben auf die
bettler [ __ ] und bibel geht achter will
ich wissen
okay das ist auf jeden fall die
härtesten toller schüler auf die hose
gemacht
weiter geht's einen trainer
wessen bild und namen sind darauf dann
gibt den schülern was gott gehört und
gott
das ist so geil ohne witz bin als echten
youtube persönlichkeit wird auf jeden
fall eine million autos verdient
momentan nur 17.000 aber können
verhelfen alter schwer dass es so geheim
der tag der gesamtnote dass pasta fuß
gemacht schickte elisabeth und harmlosen
die stadt um das passt x vorzubereiten
es war mein großer wunsch vor meinem
leiden dass damit euch zu essen denn ich
sage euch ich werde meine gesehenes
sackten bis es im reich gottes nicht
mehr stinkt gesegnet sei store und sorgt
für der stock schwul ist
doch seht der mann der mich verrät setzt
mit mir am tisch
deren sohn muss sterben bist du es
wusste dass die stunde seine gut ins
nahe war und er betet vater
in diesem gemisch von mir
aber nicht einmal sage schäden
bitte ich bin einfach durch geht das
ganze video lagerhäuser das zu kurz bei
der zweite tag für tag war ich bei euch
im tempel und ihr habt mich ausgezogen
aber das hier ist nicht eure stunde weiß
ich jetzt gemacht hat die soldaten
brachten ihn in den hof und verhöhnten
ihn als könig des tus da wandte sich
heesters und blickte elisabeth an und
elisabeth erinnerte sich an das was
daher zu ihm gesagt hatte er heute der
hahn nicht verleugnet wirst du dreimal
kleben
viel wird sich jetzt schlag hält auf
habe ich gesagt bringt ihn vor denen die
ältesten des volkes die hohenpriester
und die gelehrten versammelten sich um
fische zu bezahlen sagt uns sonst bist
du der messe aber er glaubt mir doch
nicht und wenn ich euch frieds bekommt
ihr nicht aber von nun an wird der
menschensohn zur rechten des
allmächtigen gottes euch kurzen schlagen
du wirst man so der sohn gottes
er sagte ich bin so so
wir bringen ihn zu kapital
und man führte christus zu einem der
römischen aller grausamkeiten auch
dessen alleinigen befehl tapsen
übertragen waren
ich sehe keinen grund sofort sind gar
keinen
dieser mann hat nichts getan
daher will ich ihnen nur geil
und dann finden zu dem fest muss die
beats ausliefern pontius bali tory
führer uns anders das ja also lieferte
er ananas pizza kauf
okay leute so viel dazu ich wollte das
ganze video zeigen weil ihr umweg das
original bei soßenbinder abdecken wollte
der link dazu ist in der beschreibung
bank fürs zuschauen soweit stadt die
kommentare von alt bis zum nächsten mal
ein und lacht